toi tu voulais moi également
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après avoir voulu revendre lot de tomba
comment tu as une idée j'appelle répète
à un bad buzz alors un buzz peut être
alors dit moi quand on a fait le buzz
vient à moi je ne cherche pas le buzz je
suis juste une business woman alors faut
savoir que j'ai mis en vente donc cet
article qui est l'eau de mon bain
d'accord donc l'eau vendue à 1500 euros
contre 1500 euros
loto tombe à l'eau de montbard 1510 ya
des gens qui achètent attendait cette
année c'est la finir oui
mais quoi c'est à dire tu de ben dans
l'eau et après tu prends de bruit que tu
là c'est le bain de minuit en fait moi
je fais une adepte des bains j'adore
prend des bains enfin je trouve ça juste
incroyable de prendre des bains je veux
servi mais bon j'aime beaucoup prendre
des bains et donc du coup bah j'ai
décidé d'en faire profiter à tout le
monde attend après tout se vend et tout
s'achète un
ticket ouais en fait je trouve que c'est
une sorte de du buzz un peu un peu voilà
bizarre mais c'est rien n'est pas tendu
base la gestion de l'eau d'heure non
non mais du business moi je trouve que
c'est très bien de vouloir gagner sa vie
et 1500 gaulle l'eau du bain j'ai retiré
après tout dans le contemporain ont fait
des plugs d un plug and à l'onf et le
bassin dans lequel deux autres agences
château 0 pour eux avaient donné plein
d'idées elle va vendre son plug-in est
la
prochaine étape en fait c'est votre pipi
du matin
du tout du tout du tout et tu vends tes
culottes salle voilà
non non non c'est pas des culottes celle
ses culottes que j'ai portée mais je
suis projet d'accord ne s'est pas tu les
a portés combien de fois
quelques heures quelques heures
seulement donc tu es tu verras tu les
vents elle ponctue la rencontre
s'emballe la culotte oui sans bâtiment
v8
[Applaudissements]
nobert
la vérité mademoiselle averroès
mais est ce que tu as déjà vendu des
culottes as tu as à ce que tu as dans
les décombres et jonathan sont en bois
ouais
[Applaudissements]
merci l'achète il faut bien qu'ils
sortent et sur les matières du bénin
bon et son c est ce qu est ce que vous
avez des limites là vous vendez l'eau de
votre bain à 1500 euros si un jour il ya
un homme qui me dit par exemple noté
sont vos limites si on vous dit pour
3000 me faire l'amour avec exactement
mais si vous laissez là répondre et ses
rubis puis comme un autre à yahr monde
et vous vous me dit ça mais vous vous
rendez compte nommer c'est atroce que
vous dites
si je suis moi mais j'ai pas du tout dit
non mais écoutez qui s'est brisé en
mille euros
je ne sais pas je sais mais ne vous
énervez pas
[Rires]
j'ai pas fait
[Applaudissements]
c'est fort ça
je vais des émissions politiques
mais attendez connaissez pas ce que tu
fais de tout change
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tanguy
sackboy points devant yann vince alpes a
répondu ça gros saule candidats à moi je
voulais juste pas à les faire je voulais
juste pas aller je voulais poser de
trois questions et là tu prend la
tangente que vous faites des foules
derrière les résoudre quand vous croisez
vous prenez la tangente
voilà alors donc vous vous étiez vue
avant ou pas et où vous avez essayé de
paris l'a été vous parlez moi je suis
passé devant lui je me suis pas arrêté
quoi là encore un team qui vous
interpelle vous en êtes un geek c'est en
hurlant moi je m'arrête pas enfin je
suis passé j'avais chose à faire donc il
vous a dit je voudrais te parler ou pas
du tout je sais pas ce qui m'a raconté
moi j'étais en train de descendre
l'escalator avec mes amis en train d'en
discuter avec eux d'ailleurs donc je
n'avais strictement à rien à faire de ce
qu'ils me racontent et marquer une façon
de l'aborder les gens entre sale [ __ ]
alors un coup parce que toi tu es une
autre version bah écoute c'est plus
compliqué je suis dans le métro je
marchais maire paul mais je vois je
salue moi je suis tout seul quand je
vois un renoi et là il était avec un
pote à lui et
ils étaient ils étaient allés à deux
personnes devant moi je jouis marché
était et passe devant plusieurs
personnes et quand il passe devant les
gens les gens il s'arrête et on essaie
de l'interpeller et je le vois il est là
il a fait des gestes soin et attention
il marchait je le vois je suis mort de
rire parce qu'ils marchent comme kerbala
dans le métro un prêtre et une sortie
comme ça avec son pote et marché super
vivre c'est on est 100 mille avoir des
masses qui n'ont pas de masque c'est à
dire tu vois il veut montrer on est là
tu vois on dirait était dans un clip de
rap pourtant c'est moi le rappeur tu
vois ce que je veux dire là je suis pas
sérieux et là je lui dis ouais tanguy et
sa voix mais qui se retourne il se
retourne même pas à peine comme dans la
vidéo a qu'à soi ou je sais pas j'ai pas
ce qui m'a dit va te faire [ __ ] aucun
soin que moi sa méthode la vidéo elle
est là donc à partir de là moi ça
commence à m'énerver et il se passe ce
qui se passe dans la deuxième séquence
bas je réponds pas voilà j'ai des
petites s'insultent légère
[Musique]
on m'écoute non frères ont vu tout à
l'heure pourquoi ferait on pas déjà il
veut pas 17 ans guy alors imagine frérot
je
tous les êtres humains pour moi c'est
mes frères c'est bien tous les êtres
humains si mes frères gebra bref ça
c'est une petit détail a d'ailleurs cru
que je comprends pas oui la tête à l'air
détendu youtube où elle était mais dans
le métro n'était pas comme ça et j'ai vu
fils un frère
et on sait que le phenom et dire la
vérité aux québécois une réponse il faut
faire [ __ ] agressé plusieurs on veut
pas c'est parti cosmos et ça passe pour
la première fois vers gaza
c'est à
dire en fait été accompagnée quoi c'est
ça peut se comprendre si le mec panique
et moi j'ai dit marché poitrine sortie
pas de noms mais sérieux je pense que tu
es ce que c'est toi qui l'a insulté
parce que tu pensais qu'ils voient là
non je n'ai pas insulté de façon n'y
avait qu'à voir dans sa petite vidéo la
voilà je n'insulte pas je lui parle même
pas d'ailleurs mon pote qui avec moi me
dit non mais répond pas ce type là à
temps n'occupe pas voilà tu vois bien
qu'ils qui est là pour te faire chier
lui réponds pas que je vais pas je vais
pas répondu puis abandonné d'insister
d'insister de loin donc je vais dis très
clairement je vais pas d'idée sur
[ __ ] je vais différentes agl très
clairement donc voilà c'est un peu c'est
un peu plus soft et en plus voilà et
donc
voilà tout simplement
que je commence à parler toi tu as bien
vu au moins deux petits jeunes qui vont
essayer de t'arrêter tu les envoyer
bouler c'est faux donc espérons ne pas
demander à siri de sortir les caméras du
métro non plus brefs et a couru à la fin
c'est faux si j'économise et avec son
violent mais comme on peut le voir le
couvrait parce qu'il gagnait les
gazaouis la erk je cours ou pas suivi
dans le rétro je vais prendre le métro
que je me mette à sourire ou pas est ce
que ça peut faire il était plus courir
on pas dans le métro porte mais voilà
c'est comme ça je vais taper courageux
pour la politique
non je me revois la
république c'est la guerre contre la
république contre le portugal deux
manières toi tu lâches / dégagerait
j'aime et j'admire leur est sous
pression de faire ce cas ci s'assume pas
après
moi j'ai fait des choses dans ma vie les
assiégés fait de la prison fallait
assumer je suis allé parler à quelqu'un
comme ça vous êtes en train de dire je
suis sous pression etc
je pense que n'importe qui des ducs et
où sont ces peut comprendre ce que ça
veut dire ce que les enjeux qui sont en
cours et c'est le mdi basse et arrêtent
ils étaient sous pression là-dessus et
et tanguy qu'est-ce qu'on peut n'est pas
prêt pourtant pas le mental qu'est-ce
que tu
coures archives et imec la
cour je tiens à dire messenger au moins
quelque chose de vraie société
voilà parce que je sais qu'en ce moment
tu souffres aussi si tu trouves parce
que c'est compliqué pour toi que tu
auras bien
que c'est comme ça voilà moi je porte
des convictions qui sont les miennes je
suis un républicain j'aime profondément
mon pays voilà mon engagement de tout ce
qui se passe oui
[Musique]
c'est une catastrophe cette fille-là
cette fille là c'est une catastrophe
ah bon
j'adore et morale dont je veux passer
catastrophe allait dire complètement
paumée elle est complètement paumé je
lui souhaite de ne pas rencontrer de
malheur dans sa vie mais tu es
complètement paumé faut que tu te
retrouve le plus vite possible tu peux
pas arriver là et dire je t'envie
deviner dans un hlm parce que tu es
perdu tu arrivais pas je veux
lamborghini roddis besbas dégénère il ya
des trucs intéressants c'est mon cul tu
es perdu je sais même pas que cela pour
rien de l'ambition que tu voulais moi
regarde la musique moi je t'ai pâte à
crêpes mais cette fois sur ton futur et
ce quel est ton physique mais bien
entendu voilà je fais du business je
crée d'aider des entreprises etc
voilà maintenant
je gagne bien ma vie comme la presta
créé je me donnais deux noms
d'entreprises que tu as créé geslot
demande un nom d'entreprise la première
et la deuxième ce que tu as dit je crée
des entreprises l'image que ce serait
bien que tu lises aux gens j'ai créé
plein d'entreprises et qui nous donne là
le nom de tes entreprise ça sera un bon
message pour les jeunes qui nous
regardent berne 2-3 dans trois
entreprises et des entreprises rubymine
carnon et met d'accord et en a d'autres
non je m'en fous ça lui pose des
questions je suis vraiment lé 500 1000
followers à la cua donc sa famille non
mais je pose la question ces cinq cent
mille débiles qui la suivent et pourquoi
pas et pourquoi pas maintien alors je la
fixe
et des débits
à 500000 débiles qui le suivent tu
prends l'exemple d'un monde à dire tu me
prends l'exemple doit venir du même
ouvert mon gars tu
400 milles des leaders
ah c'est toi tu vas te faire mal mais il
ya des trucs que tu 4s et des choses
pas tout seul amanda lear vraiment la
même époque il n'y avait pas les dégâts
d'internet il n'y avait pas les gens
avec cette
semaine entre eux entre l'ambition et le
michaud n'avait pas compris tout ce
monde étrange où ce que tu dis mais
laisse les parler mineuse j'aimerais
entreprises par an j'ai ma présence je
fais le test non mais qu'est ce que vous
répondez l'apaisant de la rapport à tout
ça en fait sans habiter en gros ça veut
dire que dalle est en train de me dire
que j'ai besoin d'hommes pour réussir
c'est bien ça non
non non excusez le but mathieu fabre et
et qui pour me dire que je me stein mais
je fais le redis crosby aulas
[Musique]
c'est dans ce bel animal ça me va très
bien de rod fanni rennes bat le pitch en
panne juste juste un truc du coup ça
veut dire que c'est les femmes qui vont
acheter à les culottes que tu as porté
de 6 les hommes on dépense
est ce que c'est la constitution donc je
ne demande que c'est à des célébrations
vu que c'est à destination des hommes
mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire les
hommes avec les strings apparemment tu
penses quoi qui mais c'est la
prostitution pour tous
cyril qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ces
hommes avec ses strings avec écoutez moi
je vais faire le marché avait
je suis désolé du terme et ce qu'ils
auraient tous - la vôtre c'est dire
comment je bête pour de l'argent c'est
ce que tu en prenant ses nuits en fait
non elles entendent insinué qu'ils
achètent ses culottes bourse pour pour
se masturber
tous les gens qui regardent des pornos
sont donc des miches stoner et les
filles sont des pointes et dois-je faire
pour du buzz ou tout faire pour de
l'argent c'est pas que de l'ambition et
utiliser son corps c'est cesser ces
sécrétions pour faire de l'argent et
sectionné pas mais attends tu vas me
dire que pendant longtemps on étudie la
mission on sait très bien que au bout
deux cas la prostitution moi j'ai rien
contre vous je vous respecte pas ce
texte vous fait en revanche aucun me
dire la vérité vous gagnez de l'argent
vous essayez de gagner de l'argent avec
des contenus qui sont toujours plus à
connotation sexuelle le bain sa
connotation sexuelle les culottes
segmentation c'est que vous
nous avez vous avez un site où vous
montrer toute nue aussi voilà il ya
ainsi disait ce que j'allais dire vous
êtes sur only fans et / mix sont les
sites où vous vendez 3 euros par mois
vous dénuder
[Applaudissements]
c'est
tu fais ce que tu veux y a pas de
problème en revanche le business il faut
faire attention parce que légalement il
ya plein de choses qui vont pas après
que tu fasses durable que tu sois sûr ce
vieillard l'élément gars et ça va être
abonné à votre site
oui il ya de mieux vous êtes à poil
alors
depuis que vladimir poutine a décidé
d'envahir l'ukraine selon le chaos à
travers le monde de nombreuses marques
ont décidé de stopper leurs activités en
russie par solidarité mais aussi pour
éviter de ternir leur image ce qui a
poussé airbnb microsoft ou encore apple
à suspendre leurs activités en russie
c'est aussi le cas de l'équipementier
allemand puma qui a décidé de fermer
plus de 100 magasins dans le pays une
décision prouve ukrainienne pas du goût
du rappeur booba égérie de la marque
depuis novembre 2020 vous rompez je
romps si vous faites de la politique
nous devons faire aussi mais sachez
qu'en cas d'agression la riposte sera là
c'est un homme libre qui ne veut pas
être instrumentalisée par une marque qui
n'a rien demandé la signent un contrat
commercial on veut l'entraîner sur un
terrain si on lui avait demandé son avis
il leur est donné mais là je trouve que
on l'obligé à faire quelque chose et la
rupture pour moi c'est courageux parce
qu'il se prive d'un contrat ça reste un
homme libre qu'on soit d'accord avec lui
ou pas oui quand même des pneus et c'est
ça et ça s'arrache français ça c'est ça
c'est simplissime on a l'impression
qu'ils s'y tient qui se souvient quand
même poutine je sais bien que c'est pas
si loin c'est court mais je sais bien
que c'est pas ça mais quand on connaît
rien à rien excusez moi mais ce qu'est
ce qu'il en reste et là je trouve qu'il
a tort parce qu'en ce moment il faut
vraiment être tous solidaires
je sais que l'attention dès que la
mauvaise - oui s'il avec ses idées s'il
a décidé comme il a dit vous décidez de
vous engager sur la guerre moi j'ai pas
j'ai pas j'ai pas signer avec vous pour
ça il décide d'arrêter comme vous avez
dit c'est courageux maintenant peut-être
nos courageux peut-être que courageuse
et par mer mais pour
moi parler de courage sauf que c'est
obscène en fait moi je trouve que c'est
pas du tout le buzz c'est pas du tout le
duc je trouve que c'est juste un pleutre
qui a mis un ami qui nous donne des
leçons dont je trouve que c'est
dégueulasse parce que aujourd'hui on est
en guerre et on est soit avec soit
contrée ya pas tergiversé à tordre de
comme ça et pardon mais booba a toujours
fait de la politique tout ce qu'il fait
et géraldine ils nous donnent aucune
leçon dix minutes mais lisez son
communiqué je n'ai pas signé pour ça ni
aucune leçon non mais booba ne fait que
de la politique mais vient ici il buzze
messia il fait alors ne laissez jamais
il fait que de la politique qui disent
pas que quand il paraît que vous vous
n'en faites pas oui je suis unique
chirac non mais moi si vous nous en
donner tout laisse tous les jours non
mais oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que nous en donner tous les jours des
leçons de morale et des leçons de cette
taxe à vous nous avez fait mais purement
sa vie privée les données sur le son
ouïe dans mes films et sauf que là lui
je trouve que vous narrer 10 ou
allophones de la bonne conscience
humaine et mondiale gérald il est
question comme le son est bâillonnée
quand on n'est pas pour une robe
malaisie mais bon ça fait deux heures ou
par les non j'imagine mal
rempli par leur accent vous avez parlé
tous les jours alors balesi terminé en
quoi c'est un problème de parler sous la
barre mais c'est pas ça c'est que les
volets aussi on sait que vous avez les
deux notions de mois d'années chez nous
at elle donne aux autres son analyse est
finie c'est non je le mets à dire mais
si tu as envie de savoir que c'est
indigne et c'est dégueulasse et qu'il
est du côté des collabos aujourd'hui on
est en guerre et on est soit avec qui on
est et on soit contre et on peut pas
tergiverser on est en guerre déjà on a
dit qu'on était en guerre finalement on
n'est pas en guerre c'est très cd sujet
très délicat on a dit que la france
était en guerre finalement et france et
pas en guerre faute
et tiendrait que d'ailleurs le président
de la république a dit que la france
n'était pas longtemps et ont agressé il
ya un pays qui agresse un autre pays
surnom bien sûr mais c'est pas parce
qu'on soutient c'est pas parce qu'on
soutient une population qui est
actuellement victime d'une guerre qu'il
faut se mettre à condamner tout ce qui
vient de russie liée à l'éclatement est
ce que c'est des tombes a bêtement des
symboles sa peine allégée passa passa sa
place à quelqu'un qui me dit mon fils
dit que géraldine dit n'importe quoi il
a des amis en russie ils ont accès à
tout un stade etc ils savent ce qui se
passe en ukraine et en tout cas ils sont
contents de manifester pour dire qu'ils
sont opposés au régime de poutine et son
content d'elle sur les plateaux vous
pensez que les citoyens engagés en
russie qui s'appelle oleg oleg et 10 km
aujourd'hui non soyez sérieux de
vous prêter à booba des intentions vous
dit carrément
qui a dit une bêtise mais pas par magie
chez moi j'ai jamais
[Applaudissements]
jusqu il a signé un contrat c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui dit on n'a pas signé
pour ça il a signé un contrat avec une
marque pour prêter son image aujourd'hui
cette marque se positionne de manière
très fort dans un conflit géopolitique
et booba n'a pas envie d'être assimilée
à celle gaza il rompt son contrat point
barre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]